we're going to begin with this spacex
their falcon 9 rocket is at kennedy
space center in florida this morning
gearing up for a very historic launch
why this inspiration 4 mission is
scheduled to begin tomorrow taking the
first all-civilian crew on a three-day
flight into space now their orbit will
be farther away from earth in the
international space station the mission
will also raise funds for saint jude's
children's research hospital there in
memphis haley arsenau remember that name
she is a physician assistant there and
she is one of the crew members in our
series note to self the 29 year old
louisiana native writes about her
resilience of the face of struggle and
how she earned her place on this very
special mission
five
four
three
two
one dear haley you are in for such a
wild ride
literally
liftoff of the falcon line and crew
dragon you are going on a rocket ship to
space go spacex godspeed outer space and
the whole world will be watching never
in my wildest dreams did i think i'd be
telling you this
vehicles fishing downrange i know it's
our little brother hayden who has been
in love with all things space since he
was six years old and mom and dad took
us to visit nasa and houston
remember we took pictures that made it
look like we were floating in the air
who would have ever thought you'd be
training to actually float an air
to really go to space
and i couldn't be more excited
of course hayden grew up to be an
aerospace engineer but now you were the
one going into orbit around earth for
three days and going farther into space
than any human has gone in over a dozen
years dragon separation confirmed
[Music]
i'm sure you're wondering how all this
came to be
well here's the thing
right after the trip the whole family
took to nasa
you get sick
really sick
at 10 you'll be diagnosed with bone
cancer
and go to saint jude children's research
hospital in memphis where they will save
your life
my disease is called osteosarcoma
it's very serious the chemo will be
intense
you'll lose your hair but it grows back
and better than ever
the surgeries are very difficult
you'll get a prosthesis in your leg that
enables you to walk and dance
but not jump or run
you hate the scars at first but later
you'll be proud of them and own the fact
that you look cute in shorts
physical therapy seems never ending a
total of five years of it
you can't do some things you think will
be important
[Music]
but i promise it all gets better
and you can actually do things you never
thought possible having cancer makes you
who you are
and you become stronger for it i tell
the same thing to my patients today
patience yes your patience
you will grow up to become a physician
assistant at saint jude
the bone cancer diagnosis is so scary
but saint jude becomes home
you make friends with the doctors and
nurses
some are even coming to see your space
launch
and you find hope there
you want to share that hope with other
kids going through the same thing you
will tell anyone who will listen i'm
going to work here one day and they
believe it too
because you've always been determined
and strong-willed
a cancer survivor will be one of the
first private citizens in the country to
rock it to outer space
st jude is actually the reason you're
going to space
you are chosen for the hope seat of the
inspiration for mission going out
further than the international space
station this historic first all-civilian
mission to space is raising hundreds of
millions of dollars for saint jude haley
arsenal will serve as the crew's medical
officer and you're going into space as
the youngest american the first
pediatric cancer survivor and the first
person with an internal prosthesis
you are going to space to show other
kids like you what they are capable of
you didn't just survive
you have persevered and thrived
and having cancer gives you such a love
and zest for life
and a confidence to say yes to
opportunities that could change your
life
even if they are scary
dragon spacex on the big loop
[Music]
and haley just so you know it's okay to
be scared
when saying jude invited me to go to
space my hands were shaking but i knew
it would be a once-in-a-lifetime
experience that it would help others and
that i'd grow and learn so much just
like when i did a semester by myself in
spain
i went there not knowing anybody but i
said yes and my life was so much better
for it
training for space is rigorous
modeled after nasa astronaut training
with centrifuge hypoxia zero gravity and
water survival training exercises
you'll even climb a mountain which you
dreaded the most but turned out to be
the most rewarding
you can't predict life
and for some people that's a negative
but i think of it as a positive
maybe it's because of what i've gone
through what we've gone through
there are a few important things i've
learned that i'd like to share
first to hold on to hope always
because there will be brighter days
also happiness is a choice and it's
worth choosing
there's no telling what will come next
but i'm sure enjoying the ride
love haley soon to be over 500
kilometers in space
wow hayley arsenault
oh
what a triumph yes
i i love her
i couldn't do it me neither when you
beat cancer
it creates a fearlessness yeah so her
strength is the reason why she isn't
scared to go into space she says cancer
made her who she is but i think actually
it's her triumph over it that made her
who she is and gave her that
fearlessness i like hold on to hope
always i so believe that haley happiness
is always a choice i also believe that
but shout out to haley and shout out to
the other other three jared isaacmen
he's a billionaire entrepreneur
commander of the flight sign proctor a
geology professor i love the variety of
this crew former astronaut candidate and
christopher zambroski who's a data
engineer bravo bravo and they all lift
off tomorrow we should also say a
special thank you to kyra cleveland kyra
cleveland her final producer for us yeah
this is her final piece way to go out on
a bang here well we're gonna miss you
kyra we're gonna miss you after this big
loop i wonder how many times they're
gonna do this will it happen more often
uh
not enough to get are we good are you
gonna do the show from space uh i would
actually do it i think you would not i
think you would i would i definitely
would not even though i'm afraid of
heights